how's it going BR my name
is welcome back to Martin survival I am
greeted with this handsome man hey there
Petty you like my penis no I don't but I
want to get hey there petty you're stuck
in here I want God damn you handsome
man let me go that
little come on it's got to be you will
never leave this place buy come on
the hell look at this P look at this
look
at look at me yeah you like what you see
p you like this [__] you like when my
penis is dang what the hell it let me
out I
didn't come on man what the
[__] a
God I'm going to [__] are you humping
me p oh I'm not one I'm just trying to
get
up what the [__]
man I I think
I something
there I don't thinking what the [__]
give me a second bro all right how's it
going we're back with holy [__] Mr Hand
what are you doing come here we need to
go here I can do it py I can lift it
sure you can
see I did it thank you Mr Hand I think
this is
hey why are you
whoa I think it's the end here I
replayed
everything or maybe not oh it continues
co
co the [__] am I
doing come on man who yay I surfing
or oh
whoa this is really weird whoa
what hey there how you doing is this it
Bea maybe I don't know have you fail no
I won I definitely Won Won I always win
I like your legs by the way doesn't
matter why do you ask me then trust that
you won't give up okay and that you will
fight until until the end all right if
we must battle I shall send you back to
your quest I don't even remember what it
was not
forget this
was all right oh that's what it was
saving the world
cool I knew
that oh it was what the hell am I
supposed to go down here or what
what oh what the [__] why I I I want to
swim with you ah [__] I'm SC aren't I
save me I don't better ah that was
stupid carry on my
wayward when you done why the heck did I
jump down there why did I do it not
doing that again that's what chit still
on my there we we go here we go where I
go here before oh [__] you man
oh nice explosion effect
bro ah [__] that
[__] we're good we're good we're
good [__] me ah Stars thank God I love
Stars I hate STS oh where so many come
on get it get my
get keep them over
now keep them over come on man God damn
I eat too much lately ah so many stairs
oh God it's got to be like a million
half a million what it felt like I die
all I to keep walking I I could have L
Martin and the others down I had to
think straight and keep calm keep calm
and hold
stfo okay well we keep going apparently
it's been hours hours of walking stairs
if I known oh what is it's a sup finish
another map okay
cool what the
hell oh I don't like
this [__] lion coming out of the wall
no I don't trust you whoa damn that spin
bu whoa what the [__] [__] what stop go
what Stop Bar Bar don't
bar stop
stop hey
there where did all the battel go
ow you're not going to kill me by
killing yourself you freaking suicide
bomber you are nice titties oh whoa you
are nice titties whoa there we go okay
what the [__] is going on all right
there you are Martin it is time to
finish give me the potion how the heck
will you drink that [__] anyway listen
to me give me the potion I will help you
all right trust just one
time I guess I never really gave him a
CH oh I never
again
the the I have three options I can give
ma the potion I can trust sir barlot and
give him the potion I can rescue Stefano
I give I'm gonna
give this is stupid what the hell am I
doing with the drill anyway I can't even
use the potion all right Barrel you
better not be cheating on me how do I
[__] do I I can't pick it up man ah [__]
it I'll give it to
Mu oh I just click on them all right as
M injected the potion in it made a huge
beam of light removing all the barrels
from the land piggy became a piggy
slider at the local strip club all right
no I didn't say I click I die anyway
awesome awesome cust sorry it was really
funny really funny uh well done uh thank
you br for watching probably a little
shorter episode today which is good for
me because I have a lot of stuff to do
today so I don't think I'll have that
much time but anyway so like if enjoyed
subscribe to come today and I'll see you
next episode of what I make stay awesome
Bros
[Music]
a come
on come
on I'm in a
closet I hate how he's talking it's so
[__]
creep oh [__]